Video could save your cat's life,
so please listen for your cat safety.
From time to time,
the FDA reports food that needs to be removed from
the market and taken off your cat's plate.
When cat food has been recalled,
it means it's been contaminated
and should not be fed to your pets.
Question is,
how would you know if the FDA reported that the food
you're feeding your cat is contaminated?
To help keep you up to date with the latest recalls,
we made a newsletter that will keep you informed.
Simply Google Pet King Cat Food Recall
and then click on this link,
and then from there,
you'll be able to sign up for the newsletter.
You'll then receive an email from us
every time a new food is reported.
At Pet Keen,
we are a group of cat lovers and veterinarians.
We are always up to date on this information.
Please share this information with another cat parent
and let's keep our kitties safe and happy.